I've spent the last decade tackling
struggling restaurants you're screwing
the business can't even cook
problems I'm checking in to Hotel Hell
my God
my head is spinning I'm going to be
staying in America's worst hotels so you
don't have to
I'm not sleeping here we're checking no
way it's bad this is the mattress cover
for the shower
[Music]
help
let me out
tonight I'll be trying to bring a
haunted hotel back to life
there's a little girl who supposedly
haunts the hotel
the hotel's ex-military owner I'm the
owner and I'll say that's how we're
going to do it runs a hotel like a
dictatorship oh you like a little
[__] Hitler around here damn it he's
wrong can I save a marriage in crisis
and rescue a hotel on the brink of
disaster we're gonna make it go we're
gonna shut it up sell the place sell it
because this is madness
foreign
[Music]
Cambridge Hotel in Upstate New York it's
set in stunning Countryside a few hours
drive from Manhattan
the hotel has 16 bedrooms and a large
restaurant and has had his doors open
for almost 150 years welcome to the
Cambridge Hotel ex military man and
local lawyer John imhoff persuaded his
family to help him buy the hotel in
2007.
I remember sitting in my hot tub smoking
a cigar drinking Bourbon and life was
good and I want to thank my wife
someplace nice for dinner so I said to
her why don't we buy the Cambridge Hotel
and then we'd have a place to go
he must have hit me at a weak moment
because I said sure
you hug with zero Hospitality experience
between them which one is a27 I don't
know the numbers the hotel currently
falls shockingly short of guest
expectations
and there's hair all in through here all
over these pillows be nice if we had a
remote control there's just gobs of hair
we've had remote control since when the
70s I'm not sleeping here we're checking
no way it's bad
when I bought the hotel I didn't intend
to be a Hands-On owner but I am always
at the hotel doing something one person
has to be in charge
got 84 emails 17 from John
is uh control freak how we doing on that
chicken yeah it's working hard we can do
better Chef he's ready to murder with
this menu there's a lot of restrictions
to it our budget's really tight the
creativity's kind of gone out the window
brick um all the rooms clean yeah all
the rooms coming in I am currently the
general manager X that's interesting but
John takes away my control I have no
control
but General John's Hands-On approach
isn't working nobody wants to stay and
the hotel is losing thousands of dollars
every month John wants to put every
penny that we have into this hotel and
that is something I am no longer willing
to do we are 750 000 in debt
but failure is not an option and I don't
intend to fail at the hotel unless I can
fix things and fast John and Tina will
lose their business and their home if
Gordon Ramsay can't fix us
who the hell else can
[Music]
wow the real sense of grandeur
definitely some history here Cambridge
Hotel established 1885 home of pilot
mode
I've been Across America I did not
realize it came from here
good morning
good morning welcome to the camera
uh Gordon and your first name sorry my
name is Brittany I'm the manager I have
you in room 117. that is 105 during the
weekday and 135 on the weekend okay I
think Gordon's first impression of the
hotel is going to be what the [__] are
these people doing
the Cambridge Hotel R.I.P yeah seriously
yes it's died you mean no rest in peace
is the ghost
that her live here we are haunted oh
come on there's a little girl who
supposedly haunts the hotel
Alice
[Music]
oh my good God she looks like something
out of The Exorcist she was four years
old in 1913. when she died but I believe
in ghosts at the hotel
I absolutely believe in them I'm gonna
go up the stairs as well and oh God
are they the owners no I don't know who
they are those have been here this place
is littered with freaky pictures
what's upstairs there that is our third
floor why is that roped off because it
is not accessible to our guests
well that's where people say they are
if he goes up on the third floor
he is going to freak out this is your
room
oh my God bloody hell look at the
wallpaper
what's the post up though
just there so there's no handcuffs
no okay so so it's not a sex thing
that's a really weird thing to have in
the bed I know
oh [__]
assistant
welcome to the Cambridge Hotel thank you
Christ Almighty I am not going to forget
this day in a hurry
horrible linen rough and nasty holes
look at that and the bed doesn't even
fit the base
honestly I've seen better linen inside
hospitals horrible
my bedroom is dated and uncomfortable
how could anyone think this was good
enough for paying customers bye-bye
it's gonna be the owners yes I'll be
right back with the owners
dead they are
[Music]
Gordon this is Tina and Jordan imhoff
nice to see you nice to see you nice to
meet you sir John likewise good to see
you both it's quite amazing when you
drive up and you see the sort of stature
of the building yes sir isn't it
beautiful it's stunning until we get
inside
Hotel experience prior to this was what
very very little I mean I was
none none
so year One what was the profit we lost
about 350 000 the first year year two
250 000 profit loss loss so we're in for
six hundred thousand dollars within 24
months of business who's funding this
well um my mom and dad have put in
several hundred thousand dollars
wow um our children our children your
children yes yes Shea has put about 25
000 on credit cards Shea is your the
oldest daughter your oldest daughter
right it's a chef's um significant other
okay and so my youngest daughter just
lent us ten thousand dollars your
youngest daughter she's in college how's
your house on the line next yes it is up
for sale and we would live here we would
move on to the third floor where'd you
draw the line say stop this is not
working you're standing there like proud
[__] very confident very happy and like
nothing's gone wrong but taking money
from your daughter that hasn't even
started on the path of her career I
believed that we would be able to turn
it around I know but John I'm sorry your
parents money your family's money your
daughter's money I I do have a positive
attitude there's a difference between
sounding positive and sounding
full of crap
he doesn't know me and he doesn't know
the situation I'm a military guy I'm not
going to take Chef Ramsay's [__]
just met the owners of the struggling
Cambridge Hotel and discovered they've
borrowed money from their kids to stay
open I I do have a positive attitude
there's a difference between sounding
positive and sounding
full of crap
unbelievable Tina how do you manage I
don't know how I manage and I was very
close to Running Away several times wow
seriously unreal thank you
I've been frustrated for years with him
not listening to me when somebody
doesn't listen to you for a while you
just give up
what is it about John that's driven his
wife and potential guests away I need to
watch the General in action
what do you do with the Hoover welcome
nice to see you sorry about the owner
walking through with the Hoover are you
joining us for a sleepover are you
joining us for dinner
Kim so tell me I'll help you
John Keys himself constantly busy but
he's busy doing all the wrong things
his non-stop fussing and fidgeting is
killing the hotel's atmosphere
[Music]
the tables in the bar might be clean but
I've got an eerie feeling the food's
gonna be filthy only one way to find out
hello sir how are you good my name is
Philip I'll be your server
thank you I'm a little nervous so am I
um what would you recommend well the
soup du jour today is a vegetarian
lentil vegetarian lentil yep and what
was the Super Jewel yesterday it was
awesome the vegetarian oh so soup every
two days uh actually it's longer than
two days
um I'll go for the pork and beans duck
comfy yeah
um pilot mode okay okay I think we're
done okay thank you
thank you very much chef
Chef orders up okay thank you get them
going brother get them going I think the
Gordon is going to love the food
Chef rich is great
we put out excellent food you chef
[Music]
wow look at that this is the pork and
beans
holy mackerel
it's cold in the middle both of you yeah
just touch stomach there please
touch that ice cold I can see why we've
got R.I.P on the front of the [__]
reception those are two medium rares
right scooters Chuck them in the oven
please Chef ice cold in the middle
tell them it's a sous-vide product we
cook it to order
it disappoints me a little bit that we
are boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave I wish we could actually
cook with fresher food your Duck Hunt
feet
and Chef said the pork and beans was a
sous-vide product and it's cooked to
order sous-vide oh we cooked the bag yes
they're frozen frozen yes and this plate
that's frozen I think that's a sous vide
product as well do we have anything that
is homemade are the apple pies made here
the apple pies are made here okay can
you have it with the desserts please
sure thank you
so far everything has been terrible
surely the hotel signature dish is going
to be better how's the apple pie
but if it's a home without player mode
it should be really badass
it looks like it was vomited
okay wow
put a hello mode according so this is it
this is the that is the Biola mode
[__] this plate is absolutely roasting
in the center has it been microwaved it
has
the apples are raw
if there's one thing I was expecting was
a decent apple pie and that is gross
I need to find out who's responsible for
the terrible food here
hello if Chef Ramsay criticizes Chef's
food where is the where is Chef I think
Rich will blow up because Rich does take
things personally I don't know where to
start to be honest
what the [__] is going on well tell me
what you don't like can you be a little
bit more constructive should we start
from the pork and beans Stone [__]
cold it's a sous vide product so you
don't even cook that no silly no and can
you cook yes so why buy that in
uh price you buy a store-bought frozen
piece of pork
boiled in a bag and serve it to me stone
cold in the center you're not even
cooking
so you're just too lazy to do it that's
not true I am not lazy this menu could
be run now without you being here yes
that's the way I designed it this is
where you designed it
so you are lazy then I'm not a lazy
if Gordon calls me lazier one more time
it could cause a problem
might be going back to threatening the
body bag
I just tasted the food at the Cambridge
Hotel and it was awful I think it's
because the chef is lazy but he's
adamant he's not that menu stinks of
laziness I'm not always I'm here 80 90
hours a week yeah you can't call
yourself an executive chef come on
do you know it's still bought I did why
would you employ a chef at two-thirds of
the menu is still bought
I think Gordon believes that I'm
incompetent in running a hotel but what
I'm doing is right your hotel became
famous for this apple pie right and this
is the dish that is trying to stop your
house being put up for sale to keep this
place going but I'm just what I'm trying
to say is there are so many Basics wrong
I could [__] cry I could seriously I
could cry too and look at the apples
look the apples are raw not even baked I
could scream when I see that and this
this was invented here and it's
thousands of restaurants across the
globe that have copied what you
originated have you got any idea how
lucky you are and it resolves to that
soggy undercooked soaking wet
piss pie can I have a quick word with
you for two seconds please I'm
struggling to understand what's going on
here I need to hear a woman's
perspective John
is smart in what he does as a lawyer
he's awful here I can't
get it in his head but between the two
of them they're about to take your
[__] house down him and John go back
and forth when I give suggestions it's
pretty much you know up and then it's
pushed aside and then John is making
decisions you're about to lose your
house I know and he says we are going
until I haven't got another Penny to put
in it he's never run a business before
no no and he's never done anything in
his life but be a lawyer and a soldier
that is it it may have won lots of
battles but he's [__] definitely
losing this fall let me tell you
finally a stranger is seeing what I've
been seeing and I'm hoping that John is
going to take something from this and
either we're gonna make it go
or we're gonna shut it up
[Music]
I've seen about as much as I can stand
at this hotel the outdated rooms the
cheap Linens and the pre-packaged food
how have things got this bad I've got to
get some answers
along with this place and who's to blame
problem is here is that we have to ask
to do something
we're not allowed to make a decision
general manager executive chef we have
to run everything through John make sure
everything else
you have to ask someone that doesn't
know how to run a [__]
[__] let alone the hotel but he took
over more control that's when I put on
my hands okay you want to run it you run
it it's [__] soulless it's littered
with [__] and things that are broken
it's got horrendous pictures all over
the [__] place disgusting rooms food
that comes out of a [__] bag and I
don't control any of that stuff I'm not
making decisions I told Rich that I
thought we should cut our food costs
have you got the respect
from the owners to do your job properly
yes or no no I
decisions that
should be able to though because she's
telling you that and that's what the
problem is it's not the [__] ghost
John that's scaring the regulars away
it's you
a chef needs to be a [__] chef and a
general manager needs to General manage
I'm not a micro manager
when we first started this place and the
ideas I had were all shot shot down
that's the kind of stuff now it's coming
out you've handicapped the chef the
general managed this functional and
you're calling all the [__] shots I'm
not calling the shark you're a Lethal
Weapon well you may think that no I
don't think that I [__] know that not
just heard from your wife your general
manager your Chef that I'm controlling
Over Control you like a little [__]
Hitler around here and if you don't stop
doing what you're doing
you lose your family and The Business
[Music]
finally got to the truth at the
Cambridge Hotel you're like a little
[__] Hitler around here the place is
sinking because John the owner's
meddling ways have made everyone's jobs
impossible I'm not a micromanager
they're not puppets
they're your team and if you don't stop
doing what you're doing you'll lose your
family and The Business
work it out your honor hang on to bed
good night
this is all stuff that I've been trying
to get across to John for 20 years
foreign
what's the matter
seriously yeah what's the matter with
you right now we have a headache again
I've had it
I have had it I was feeling squashed
and I don't have to feel that way
anymore
I'm not going to feel that way anymore
bedtime and I'm not looking forward to
sleeping in a haunted room I've never
seen such a delusional owner
and staff that are so desperate to do
their jobs
I now want to sleep in this
oh [__] what was that
this bed is so uncomfy
what is that noise on the stairs
I had a sleepless night and believe me
it wasn't a ghost that kept me awake it
was something far more frightening time
to give John and Tina a wake-up call
after you please
thank you
these are the guests that have been
staying in the hotel
um I've asked them in my room this
morning as to help you understand how
difficult it has become for guests to
actually stay here who would like to go
first I took shower this morning and
used what I thought was a clean towel
and there was hair in the towel
the batter itself was actually very
uncomfortable yeah
so we had to leave our hotel room door
unlocked
hand on Hearts how many of you would
return here no yeah anyone
not unless you pay me to stay here
John and Tina are you aware of so many
problems inside these rooms
yeah
but I'm more
pissed off about about anything is that
last night I went downstairs
in fact let me show you it's easier if I
do it this way I forgot my toothbrush I
went down to the car
and I cannot believe this just watch
carefully
I went outside
so step down the stairs
and all of a sudden damn I locked myself
out I've got no keys to get back in
the bloody front door
is not locked at night now
there's no night Porter there's no
security and then
shock horror
I went behind the reception desk and
every one of your keys is hanging
replicated in the pigeon box
wow that's terrible
duplicate key for every room oh my God
credit card details personal cell
numbers it's all there yeah
why is the door not locked
there's no good reason yeah we haven't
locked in a long time though no about
two years in this community you have
eight major burglars in the last 12
months three registered sex offenders
locally in this community I mean how
does that make you feel that we were
sleeping in this hotel last night and
each and every one of us
was vulnerable
that's not okay so irresponsible thank
you thank you guys thank you can you
stay here with me and ladies and
gentlemen thank you
thank you John and Tina have broken the
first law of hospitality keep your guess
safe John's so busy interfering with
other people's jobs he's lost sight of
what really matters
I'm not joking around on the burglaries
the sex offender I know I know your
reputation can be over in seconds on one
incident in this hotel
because you're not going to walk around
this town
has a prosecutor a chief lawyer
and then be responsible for a serious
rape taken in place inside here
wake up
you're running a business not a
courtroom
and they're here for an experience not a
[__] sentence
sell the place because you're not fit to
run it sell it
because this is madness
sell it
and keep your house
worth it
[Music]
thank you
I've just discovered that John has lost
sight of the big picture at the hotel
the bloody front door
is not locked at night and his
incompetence is putting the guest safety
in jeopardy
John doesn't change his interfering ways
he and Tina will lose their home and be
forced to live in the hotel's top floor
it's time to find out what it's like up
there
[Music]
hello anyone there hello
it's like summer oh [__]
out
who in the hell we'll put this here this
really is Hotel Hell
oh God Welcome to our hands
this place is genuinely disturbing
freaky
laptop floors no place to live but I've
got a plan if I force John to see how
different things could be here maybe
he'll get the message so I'm gonna need
Britney's help if we can prove to John
and Tina if you take charge and you hold
those reins but you can make money in
this hotel
trust me they back off and you step up
okay yeah absolutely I'm here I'm hoping
to prove to John that it can be busy it
can be fun here tonight we are serving
we are doing a bar night oh my God this
is terrible we're not a
Rowdy kid doing shots going crazy bar
that's a party party party and we're
gonna do a drink specials we can get
people in the rooms a ladies night
tonight have to pack the place thanks
bye
this is the first step to change as last
minute preparations take place in the
bar in the kitchen there's a new energy
in the hotel
this is Chef Richie's chance to prove he
can cook with fresh ingredients nothing
out of a bag please no preheated all
fresher all fresh great Rich it's your
responsibility to teach these guys how
to cook absolutely not to reheat is that
right scoop yeah yeah absolutely it's
just sort of culinary school oh good man
how do you inspired you to be a chef I
heard relatives everywhere pushing me to
join a culinary field because
I wasn't physically able to do any other
things like sports and stuff yeah what's
the disability I've had two heart
surgeries and two back surgeries how old
are you 19. yeah you move fast that's a
big asset they haven't been taught
properly yet have you no that's
incredible so what do you want to be
when you grow up
um I would like to have my own Bakery
and be a professional executive pastry
chef wow we're ready to roll
Brittany has gotten the word out but
she's in charge tonight and people are
flocking into the hotel
there's a
lot of Ages here and everyone hanging
out together and having fun
what can I do to help you nothing get
out
that's going great but I don't think
John quite understands how important
nights like this are because I don't
think this guy gets the message
John
I want to show you something come with
me
[Music]
that thing Spooks me every time I come
in here
is the situation
downstairs currently there's a buzz and
they got put together by your general
manager Brittany that's her vision but
if you carry on running
the Cambridge the way you have been this
is what you're gonna have this is what's
your destiny this on your own so stay up
here
and sort of enjoy your surroundings
how can we get you when I'm ready all
right
foreign
he's so wrong he has no clue and I'm I'm
thinking when he comes back up he's
going to ask me what did I learn and I'm
going to say to him I really didn't
learn anything
pluck damn it
I've locked John the hotel's interfering
owner on the top floor I need to
demonstrate to him how well the hotel
can run without him
I'm not happy sitting there waiting
because I know my guests are downstairs
having a party
and I kind of felt that I needed to be
downstairs
Ford who's wants me to sit up here and
and think that he's all right about all
this stuff and damn it he's wrong about
me being a control freak
with ladies night in full swing she has
fiance and John Tina's daughter Shea
arrives to join in the fun
[Music]
I think she's my last chance of getting
through to John hi Shane hey how are you
I've got one minute 30 seconds please
excuse me thank you
time running out for your dad for your
mother and for their house I can't get
through to your father
I asked him to go upstairs and just sit
and Ponder and think that this is your
future then you think he's ready to
change by all means bring him down and
if he's not I don't care keep him out of
there and keep him up there
what's going on I'm just up here uh
sitting down and waiting waiting to go
back downstairs
I think the point
um
was to try and visualize what
could potentially be
the future oh no I've been doing a lot
of thinking okay I've been doing a lot
of thinking
I thought my role was about the same all
along
I feel like it's changed a lot and I
think a lot of it is
a fear of trusting
you don't have to be here all the time
when was the last time you sat down at
home and had a dinner with Mom you know
yeah I feel guilty when I'm not here
do you know what's going on downstairs
no
it's awesome there is a restaurant full
of people that are thoroughly enjoying
themselves it's happened
and it's working without you yeah
yeah I'm getting it okay I mean I'm it's
going to be tough for me to backlog of
the working I think it's important for
you I think it's important for you and
Mom
yeah you're making good points Jay
I think you would be able to spend more
time with your granddaughter oh I'd love
that
it's possible
you don't want this to be your future
you don't want to live here no I don't
you have to commit to change yeah yeah
I I understand
if Mom will put up with me being home
more
love you I love you too Shay oh
I I've it's an epiphany I've I've just
now realized my control is what Dre is
dragging the hotel down now I need to
make a change in order for my personal
life to improve and for my business to
get better
thank you
tonight has been a real success seeing
Brittany in charge and Rich cooking
fresh food gives me real hope but is
John capable of letting go
my goodness it feels weird it's sounding
so quiet now right uh well done behind
the bar well done in the kitchen
scooter well done ladies great I mean
you can get a seat at the bar within 20
minutes that's how it should be how much
do we take it's under fourteen hundred
dollars in two hours fourteen hundred
dollars
in two hours we made more than the last
four Wednesdays or four Thursdays
combined Johnny you spend the majority
of night upstairs how was your night it
was in a very good night actually
in what way
um my daughter Shay um opened my eyes to
some things I'm here every night because
I feel that I need to be here that that
is my role as the owner
to wave the flag as a military term but
when I when it came from Shea as she
said you know Dad
I know how hard you work and and I
promised I wasn't going to tear up
and uh this all happened without me you
trust your subordinates as a commander
the most important person you have are
your ncos and Chef and Brittany are my
ncos I can't tell you how good it is to
hear that because you're a [__] tough
nut to crack
because we have got one hell of a day
tomorrow
but I need everybody everybody at their
best
good job
what are they
I'm hoping that John has finally got
that message but is it all loyal crap
tomorrow we'll definitely find out
freezing
[Music]
coming up I dragged the Cambridge Hotel
into the 21st century and one of the
hotel staff gets some shocking news
my design team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new Cambridge Hotel
to the staff good morning good morning
John how you feeling I can't wait to see
what you've done in there right you
ready to go in yes the only way we're
getting in is with this a key let's go
let's go the door is locked so your
guests can sleep safe and sound come in
unlocks good good right come upstairs
I'm hoping you're gonna love my room I
think it's absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
oh I'm putting that flooring in
absolutely transformed it
the wallpaper was expensive in order to
enhance it we work with it
so we've got the back drapes above the
vet we have this amazing new floor yes
perfect furniture that fits the room
we've upgraded every room with brand new
linen and towels 75 000 worth of linen
oh my God oh my God we could have never
afforded that that is so wonderful I
feel like kind of like a kid that comes
down Christmas morning and there's so
many things under the tree that you're
you're in overload I can't really
comprehend everything yet I mean I'm
just kind of looking at it saying wow
ready for one more room oh my God I
don't know if I could take it wow
wow wow
I can't wait to actually show a guest
upstairs to a room I love it I love it I
love it
um there's one more little thing I want
to show you downstairs come with me
please in the 1890s the Cambridge Hotel
gave birth to world famous piler mode
and I think that dish can put the hotel
back on the map today something I
thought was a huge missed opportunity
I've been working on an amazing very
special
apple pie recipe that I'm going to give
to you that you own and it becomes the
best apple pie in America and on the
back of that
we've transformed this room through here
to the alamode room come through
morning everybody how are we
can sell our own pie that's homemade
that Gordon is giving us his recipe for
oh my God this hotel invented pile of
mode and the ice cream is made fresh
here with a brand new ice cream maker
and it's
locally sauce cream I can't wait to try
it
come with me please enjoy the apple pie
nice to see
please come through beautiful pile of
mode
digging digging come on guys
if anybody wants this you better get on
it
[Music]
oh my God that's awesome the world
famous Cambridge Hotel apple pie ala
mode
that is the best crust I have ever had
on a pie
CE welcome to the Cambridge Hotel we now
have the best apple pile mode in I'd say
the world people are gonna be excited
scary what do you think bud I'm shocked
you're shocked are you happy
little Lord say oh mate don't get upset
buddy
what's the matter I'm so happy oh good
I'm happy too as well you know that okay
seeing how much you change the hotel is
very overwhelming
I can feel a chance I'm a lot more
inspired right now I feel like I could
accomplish anything in the kitchen
I am proud now there's a new pride in me
to say
this is where I work
time to go I never thought I'd say this
but I'm actually quite sad to leave this
place because no longer is John in
denial he can now stand back and watch
his team run the Cambridge properly
as I'm getting ready to leave guests are
starting to arrive at the new hotel
change of all is that the new Decor it's
the fact the guests are loving it at the
Cambridge
this is beautiful
the restaurant is buzzing the Cambridge
burger with the pork belly guests are
enjoying the new home cooked menu that I
put together with Chef Rich
you better save room for the pie because
it's totally different
apple pie and the hotel's signature dish
piler mode is a big hit and that ice
cream is worth driving for fantastic
great buzz in there I mean it's electric
and it's the sound of the new Cambridge
Hotel only hope now is that they keep it
up and keep those customers excited
because when it's like that it's
phenomenal
they're good
I think tonight went incredibly well the
fact that I could stay and sit with Shay
and Addison and funk
it was really really nice
[Music]
wow
to see you smiling is incredible you
know that you light this place up but I
don't want you living here no I'm not I
don't want to live here I do not want
you living here I won't live here okay
tell him that I'm not living here I hear
you I'll give him a hug you do that one
he hasn't interfere tonight and you sat
down and spent time with your
granddaughter I had a blast yeah my job
is done let me tell you no longer
R.I.P okay of the Cambridge it has a
bright future long live the Cambridge
right absolutely right before Gordon
came I didn't know where to go anymore
with the hotel and getting Gordon here
and having him show us what the problem
was now I can see that the things can be
fixed I'll tell you okay Colin Powell
says optimism is a force multiplier
I'm optimistic stay optimistic but don't
get too involved okay okay
look after yourselves thank you very
much stay together thank you thank you
thank you
before I leave this place there's one
more person I want to talk to come on a
big man so you've got three more years
left at college right about four okay
hear me out okay I want you to keep in
touch with me okay I'll give you my
email address because I want to finance
those next four years in college
personally and help you okay do it for
you and keep that dream alive one day of
owning your bakery and then when your
bakery is open all I want back is a loaf
of bread
okay it's pretty unbelievable that he is
going to be able to finance my four
years of school well done good job thank
you well done thank you I'm waiting to
finish school who came off for that big
loaf of bread
you have an amazing Pair of Hands and a
lovely smile don't stop okay and God
help you if you fail that college thank
you you won't though I know you won't
well done thank you okay when I go to
school I'm gonna push myself 200 times
harder I'm gonna show Goran what I can
do and how fast I can do it good night
thank you very much thank you take care
thank you well done thank you oh good
job man awesome job hey you deserve it
definitely
what a week what a place
and now whenever I see yellow mode I
know where it started
tonight on Hotel Hell
I'll be investigating a murder mystery
in the Idaho town I've called the lane
isn't a person
it's the Roosevelt Inn
[Music]
there are plenty of Clues as I dust the
fingerprints like someone's ashes
and uncover
horrific stains oh gosh brilliant Prime
Suspect is the owner a Sherlock Holmes
wannabe who disguised himself as a chef
though we must coxy fabulous food I
can't even boil an egg I was wrong
[Music]
you're a [__] joke I'm gonna kill him
just talk to my hand I've got to solve
the case before there's another victim
the owner's marriage I just feel like
I'm
I'm gonna suffocate
[Music]
foreign
by stunning lakes and close to two major
ski resorts Cordell Lane is one of
Idaho's Premier vacation destinations
it's also home to the Roosevelt Inn
the Inn is a 16 bedroom converted
Schoolhouse owned and run by one of its
former students John Hoff
the Roosevelt Inn is the first hotel
I've ever actually owned I was up here
signing the papers and I called my wife
Tina and I say we now own the Roosevelt
town and all of a sudden I hear this
started crying I did not want to buy the
hotel but John really did I have told
John many times that he won't be cold in
the ground and I'm on my way home to
Kentucky
the Roosevelt Inn is not just hell for
Tina it's hell for the guests who have
to put up with the consequences of Jon's
eccentric Behavior sorry we're not
trying to be a pain yes you are I would
say that the hotel is struggling because
it's dated it's old
probably because it is old and the food
coming out of the Inn's shoebox sized
kitchen is as bad as the decor
strong fish flavor oblivious to the
problems John's performance never stops
I'll ask you questions you'll give me
answers I'll ask questions you'll give
answers and I'll ask you questions
you'll give me answers as John is more
focused on playing dress-up how was that
Watson then I'm being an Innkeeper John
refuses to grow old gracefully it's
Halloween for John every day he loves to
dress up it's the cast it's the bloody
curse once a month at the Roosevelt we
put on a murder mystery and dinner how's
everything going in here for you
I basically do everything uh you want to
finish making up this bed and I'll do
the bathroom okay great I feel my dad
doesn't appreciate my mom my mom works
three times harder than my dad does
there are times that I'll come in and
she's out busy doing something and he's
sitting on the couch reading a book as
the business has suffered so as John and
Tina's relationship we actually had to
go through marriage counseling I don't
think John understands the sacrifice
I've made unless I can get this place on
the road to recovery John and Tina will
lose everything if I lose the Roosevelt
I don't just lose my job I lose my home
I become unemployed and homeless and one
fell asleep I don't think we're gonna
pull out of this one
I'm hearing curdor Lane Idaho I
seriously hope this place is better than
the other shithols I've stayed in oh my
God
look at that they say all publicity is
good publicity but the billboard that
old-fashioned
I'm not so sure you're [__] joking at
him come on
Roosevelt Inn Bed and Breakfast it's
like something at The Adams Family the
Roosevelt School the place looks Grim
from the outside
hello welcome to the Roosevelt good to
see you I recognize that voice your
Gordon Ramsay okay my God look at those
chairs there are they from school they
are those came out of the first grade
classroom oh look you almost fit are you
reception
first impression from the outside it's
almost like walking to your funeral
parlor oh
it smells like [__] as well what is that
is that the dog let's do a oh boy I sure
hope not
um
this is her dining room who's the chef
here I saw a billboard of a guy with the
most hideous hat on covered in trees and
like this six foot hats
kind of grown into Jean piazi mad French
chef de Roosevelt because you're in
Coeur d'Alene is a French named Tom noon
also we must cook fabulous food a boy
this outfit
now you'll see uh School photos yes down
the hallway here and these are of kids
that went to school here at the
Roosevelt and the ones with the arrows
pointing at the really cute adorable
little boy that's me of course because I
went to school here oh you went to my
Elementary School
who wants to live in their old school
it's like getting a detention That Never
Ends the guests get to hang out down
here with the dogs and watch TV you are
kidding me
you can't smell those dogs oh yes I can
the dogs actually believe it or not
Gordon
are one of the highlights highlight here
now you're sounding deluded
what's next our little Ballroom or our
multi-purpose room oh come on Rohan
you're not supposed to be in this room
don't you think this place could at
least had some form of makeover well
sadly Gordon we renovated this room four
years ago
this is new stuff now this room looks
like it was last decorated in 1908 not
2008. how much do you spend on this
fifty four thousand fifty four thousand
five four
not 5400 54 000. I know lovely huh
Christopher and does it generate money
no I can't believe anyone would want to
rent in that space it's hideous I'm
dying to have a look upstairs it can't
get any worse it could get worse and
what's your uh occupancy across the year
probably around mid-20s 20 across the
board ouch I'm amazed you find it so
funny this is your room
okay what's with all the pink it's like
someone threw up strawberry milkshake
all over the place my room has two
levels
eat as bad as the other oh everything
looks like we're in a Time Warp I mean
it is so dated
so my room how much do you pay to stay
in here uh 319
319 bloody hell I'm speechless
[Laughter]
13 year old Decor 319 a night can I ask
you something fire away why do you think
everything's a big joke
because you're very critical I'm here to
get this place right but what I don't
understand is how blase you are
situation I'm gonna give you the truth
and if you don't like that then I'm out
of it what do you want me to do I'm
angry and punch you you want to punch me
maybe I do want to punch you a little
bit but I can become physically very
very violent and have in the past people
get hurt
John John
you can't just walk away where are you
going
[Music]
Since I checked into Idaho's Roosevelt
Inn I'd be unimpressed by the horrible
Decor what's with all the pink but it's
like someone's vomited everywhere and
the dated event space that smells like
wet dog the dogs actually are one of the
highlights but the biggest problem here
is the owner John who seems to think
it's funny that he's in is a disgrace
the only time he stopped laughing was
when I confronted him with how bad
things really are here what I don't
understand is how blase you are the
situation
situation John you can't just walk away
while John hides from the truth
downstairs I'm gonna have a closer look
at my room
blue mess
that's what the rugs on the floor for
just grass look at the dust on there
most disgusting of all [__] is the dust
magnet hanging over my pillows
[Music]
how long has that thing been up there
how
let me out
I hope I'll get a sense of what's really
going on here from John's wife Tina
Gordon this is my lovely wife how are
you I'm stressed out
what hotel were you winning before this
I was running a dental office I worked
in a dental office I wasn't running
anything except my home so why would you
go from sort of teeth to Hotel because
he bought a hotel so you bought the
hotel it was my negotiation
you negotiated you both bought it yes
yes willingly or unwillingly unwillingly
I was very happy and content with the
life that we had so when John told me
that we were buying the Roosevelt I
burst into tears how much did you buy
for seven hundred thousand so
spend on we owe one million 100 000.
obviously you haven't paid back the debt
yet to the bank owner yeah no the bank
owns US sold our house we had here
cashed in a 401k everything we had oh my
words where's your house now what do you
live in we live up in the attic
this is my help I have had terrible
experiences here business experience
financial hardship everything's just
Fallen apart here for me
you seem serious you seem joking it's
almost like you're playing at it it is
kind of an entertainment though
to a certain degree at 1.1 million
dollars that's an expensive
entertainment well yeah I didn't realize
it was this bad how's the relationship
we're in a rough place
we went through marriage counseling what
was that four or five years ago
because of this business oh yeah and
still working together seven days a week
yes 24 7. I'm ready for something to
change I'm ready for anything at this
point I just feel like I'm
I'm gonna suffocate I'm gonna get my uh
bag unpacked and I'll uh I'll catch up
with you later thank you Tina looks
ready to bail out and all John can do is
laugh he thinks being over a million
dollars in debt is entertainment I think
this marriage is in as much trouble as
the end clearly in denial but more
importantly
man that won't man up and take
responsibility
[Music]
I've been told that tonight the
Roosevelt Inn is holding a murder
mystery dinner it's an event they host
once a month I have a feeling it's gonna
be hard to forget
head of your head on into that I'll get
you all checked in ready to go you look
fabulous we usually always have a lot of
fun with this we're going to continue to
have fun with this are you dressing that
this evening I play the part of Sherlock
Holmes old man you're playing an
Englishman I am playing an Englishman
and I even have the pipe to go with it
I've studied this accent long and hard
in fact mine is better than normal
tradition
actually don't know where Gordon got his
accent he obviously doesn't practice it
very much mine is far more authentic
than his is
absolutely yes wow
while John Prince is around at Sherlock
Holmes I wonder what Taylor does during
these events
oh my god what have you got on this is
crazy
it's not a mystery night sir it's gone
from an end to little house and Prairie
I mean honestly it'll be my job this
evening to cook your dinner so while
John gets to play Sherlock Holmes his
wife is stuck in the kitchen wake up
John this is not the 1800s anymore John
definitely like dressing up more for the
murder mysteries because he's not in the
hot kitchen he's out there Hamming it up
with the guests playing Sherlock Holmes
okay
right
um
to make all this is a little bit bizarre
slightly weird I wonder if this event
even makes any money is this profitable
it is profitable
yeah it's a lot of work I mean we made
2008 200 for all this work and are they
all staying oh no what's the locals you
know when they come for a murder mystery
they usually don't do an overnight
clearly tonight's about feeding John's
ego not filling his bank account oh well
that that could explain it then yeah oh
here now oh my word should I say oh my
[__] god hell come to me sir ladies
and gentlemen it appears the game is
afoot you know their goal with the
murder mysteries has always been to get
people in but I'm not filling the rooms
what's the point
[Music]
and I would have called away with it too
if it wasn't for you and your meddling
guests
well there you have it brilliant of all
of you
thank goodness that's over it's time to
find out from John what on Earth he
thinks he's doing
sit down you must be shattered I'm tired
I bet you are sticker fork in me it's
Matt was it mad yeah
you're in the kitchen busting your ass
off working hard to serve all those
people and John you were out prancing
around like a sort of actor the thespian
thing it's an inn it's not a theater but
you seem to enjoy it you have to force
yourself to like doing it I mean it's on
stage for three hours and
the problems at the Roosevelt are
Elementary can I just never work with
you on your own oh sure
this place is sinking because John
refuses to take anything seriously you
love being an Entertainer don't you dare
tell me that that is hardly this whole
[__] thing was put together for your
fantasy well that's kind of what this
night is it is entertainment we put on a
show
you're pretending to be Sherlock Holmes
and upstairs we're empty you're in the
[__] financially we're in Ruins and if
you put the same amount of effort into
filling this place just one
room book tonight would have made more
profit than the whole murder mystery and
all that work that went into it I mean
this is insane and you prance around
like some [__] idiot while your wife
is slaving away in the kitchen do you
have any care in the world apart for
yourself
you get a psychology degree oh when I go
you come and tell me what's wrong with
me here we go you obviously think you
are psychologist denial again no I'm not
in denial I just don't know what you
want it's only your own [__]
stupidity to why we're in the [__] this
far well that is probably true so then
man up and act responsible
[Music]
you need to grow up and stop running
away from the truth
joke
it was Roosevelt in
meows and last night proved to me that
owner John needs to stop dressing up
wait till I get going and start growing
up you prance around like some [__]
idiot and take some responsibility for
the problems at the end it's only your
own [__] stupidity to why we're in
the [__] I'm done with that but John
didn't want to listen just talk to my
hand you know oh what a [__] idiot
yeah
today I'll have another go at getting
through to him before he heads into the
kitchen to prepare lunch
you're losing money you're on this
treadmill of mistake after mistake we
may be in a elementary school but you're
not a child and I would really wish if
you stop acting like one quickly is that
possible
[Music]
show me what you got
ta get that I don't want to cook for
gardening I mean first of all he's got a
huge Eagle of his own so you know
nothing anybody else does is going to be
any good I don't even want to cook him a
thing how are we doing over here where
to spread that I'm in town and the
dining room is full we're all having the
same five core set menu cooked in the
Inn's Tiny Kitchen
starch off
thank you
that's the girl sleep wow what the
watery bits what's that
um that's probably the tomato juice
unless it's condensation from the shrimp
condensation was it fresh yes
yeah warm it's a sad looking shrimp
that's not good stuff
I will take that for you and everyone
else seems to be hating it too how can
you [__] up
okay here's Gordon's pecan crusted a
salmon is it fresh salmon Frozen that
has to be the saddest looking plate of
salmon anywhere in North America tonight
[Music]
seasoning is triple very dry would you
like me a ticket for you yes please I'm
sorry she'll take everything
tastes great to me
I'm gonna kill him I just want Gordon to
take a long walk off a short pier I want
him to fall into a very deep pit
so he can't get out
this is pathetic can John cook anything
he can cook an egg
sure thing it can't possibly mess up a
soft boiled egg can he soft-boiled egg
for orange okay what soft boiled egg
what
I'm just like going
wow
[Music]
thank you
I'll make my own egg cup okay
[Music]
that was a roll is this really happening
he can't even boil a [__] egg
[__] thing's still got feathers on it
we probably cooked out another two
minutes
I'm absolutely ready to boot Gordon
Ramsay out of my hand
[Music]
fire away buddy are you having a laugh
are your family's expense no
big tall hat big jacket and you can't
boil a [__] egg you're on it fried
egg
you want french toast too how about some
pancakes oh [__] are you doing
you don't care do you I do care you're a
[__] joke
those are what we refer to as fighting
words gutsy thing to do especially in a
kitchen full of sharp knives it has
never been a joke for me ever come play
at my school I'm the Headmaster you're
acting like an absolute idiot no but
you're in my house that's right I'm
disgusted at your performance your big
problem is you can't handle the truth
you don't like hearing it you don't even
know me
just a joke think about your wife you're
in to 1.1 million dollars of debt you're
forcing her to live in Hell she's
telling me that I just think over the
last 13 years but what you've [__]
done
and not to you it's every outstanding
behind you I'm tired of hearing that I
don't need it anymore
screw it I really don't care if he
leaves [__] man
oh
I had a horrible night's sleep on the
couch because I couldn't sleep in my bed
I really need a hot shower
oh [__] [__] you know this water's
freezing I need to open John's eyes but
he walks out every time things get
difficult so I've got another plan have
you got two minutes we do there's
something I'd like to show you both in
my uh my room oh crap
what now
what's wrong
now
[Music]
there's the jury and they're going to
hang us potato you recognize some of
your guests from the past six months we
do I think feedback is critical First
Impressions walking through the door a
lot of decorations
it wasn't the value that we paid
honestly show of hands how many of you
would return and stay here again please
none of our guests would return
I'm kind of speechless I
I didn't expect this I thought it was I
thought we were better than that that's
the most valuable information you've had
in 13 years I thought we were a lot
better than this and that that is a view
that is changing you've got to put
yourself in the guest position
you know you've given me feedback on
everything you've seen and experienced
but there's something I'd like to point
out that none of you see
please
would you be so kind to put a pair of
these on please
oh my gosh and let's just get
any more terrible I don't think so last
season
okay this black light is going to show
up any bodily fluids
the uh the pillows show
yes sir
oh my God like someone urinated on it
absolutely disgusting
if you think that's bad
[Music]
this kind of stuff hasn't been weeks
that's that's years
[Music]
absolutely hideous horrified disgusted
grossed out
kind of want to go vomit
oh you kind of trust that things are
going to be you have the rightness and
you you have that this is just as bad as
it can possibly be I mean I'm disgusted
I
laugh
how does that make you feel everything
he actually feel sickness
thought I took a shower but now I'm
gonna
Wonder I'll let you go thank you
thank you very much thank you
this is me I mean I've put my heart and
soul into this
[Music]
it won't listen to me and John just
laughs at every problem
[Music]
I'm worried about Tina hearing from the
guests and seeing those stains seem to
hit her pretty hard Tina yes have you
got two sets
I'm not here to hurt you I'm here to
help you I'm just banging my head
against the wall with John no no we do
is not perfect but I thought what we did
was better than that
it's got to get out of this bubble
he's an Innkeeper
but he's constantly joking and shrugging
responsibility and now he has to start
looking at himself
the thing that probably bothers me the
most is John just refuses to understand
my need to have my part of the dream I
don't like living and eating and
breathing my work 24 7 and never ever
having a place to go that I can get away
they're not happy
I'm happy no
I'm not
at the end of the day I usually lay down
the bed and I know this is what I wanted
and I'd leave here tomorrow if I could
leave here tomorrow I'm ready just walk
away from this and just forget it I'm
gonna leave I want to get out of here
and go away
come give up 13 years of being unhappy
is not immobile it's a mountain if you
have a voice you've got to stand up you
absolutely have the right to be happy
I guess maybe I needed somebody to say
you have a right to be happy
so that was good thank you
I'll see you later okay I promise you
I'll make a difference and I mean that
last night John's wife Tina was at a
breaking point I feel happy oh and I'd
leave here tomorrow if I could leave
here tomorrow after talking I realized
how bad things really are here and I
promise to make things better because
Tina truly deserves to be happy
good morning Daddy good morning how are
you
I'm I'm here you're here
um let's catch up Joey let's get out of
this little cubby hole okay
um maybe downstairs
I can't believe that John and Tina have
spent sixty thousand dollars on a
ballroom that they never used and smells
like dog looking at this Inn there's a
huge missed opportunity the potential of
this room is extraordinary and this has
to be used as a way to get people into
the bedrooms upstairs and make money
exactly how often do you use this room
twice a month oh no that's crazy it is
have you ever thought about employing a
wedding planner to actually book this
place out I have one I'm working with
and working with her for just about a
year now I don't pay her a salary it's
her wedding if we score a wedding we
both get paid so she's motivated to sell
it
for me it's a big missed opportunity
yeah once you've held an amazing wedding
and you've got such great feedback it
just spreads okay this is what I want to
see I'll see you later yeah thank you
this does not Stack Up
I'm gonna go meet the wedding planner
because
it must be something that John and Tina
aren't telling me
hello how are you nice to me where
should we start well you want to come on
over and we'll have a seat shall we yes
come on over
the rose events um what would you say
the key problems it's dated it's it's
hard to sell 10 day old bread right you
know braids are young they're
sophisticated they're on their phones
they're seeing with the rest of the
world is doing you know a big thing with
selling the ballroom is the colors that
only matches a tiny percentage you can
either go burgundy Ivory or navy blue
and those colors are so dated anyways
it's terrible and then you walk
downstairs and the smell I had one girl
literally say I've got to go upstairs
the smell is going to make me sick
John doesn't strike me as someone that
I'd want to put my wedding in his hands
as a host how is he we have had some
issues last summer with him coming out
and dancing
at the guest wedding yes like ballroom
dancing or it was more like Macarena
type line dancing style oh my God I mean
how awkward was that it was mortifying
if you just bear with me whilst I make
some changes because I mean you are the
key to their success going forward would
you give them one more chance
I'm in thank you good to see you thank
you thank you Don
now that Misty is on board to help the
Roosevelt I'm gonna make one last
attempt to see if John is ready to
change
[Music]
I'm not here to hurt your feelings John
but you have
a huge defense mechanism I have an
attitude I want to help but you are a
very tough stubborn
selfish individual to get through to
yeah it hurts it's not a sign of
weakness to put your hand up and ask for
help
[Music]
and I don't want to perhaps
I don't want about hats either
Gordon I've got two options here I can
close up the business walk away from it
give it to the bank
the other option is
I know I've done this to myself I've
done this to my wife
I've got to find a way to get out of it
this has been your dream your ambition
and she just followed suit you're
correct you have one amazing loyal lady
there I don't deserve her
I'm a pig sometimes there's just no
doubt about it
yeah
trying to change that she's not the one
that should be suffering because of what
I did and
considered that in yours
let's start making this place better I
need you committed
I want the help I want to make this work
[Music]
coming up as John's change come too late
I've
quit dreaming
now that John's finally turned the
corner I'm a pig sometimes trying to
change that it's time to sit down with
Tina and get to the heart of their
relationship I'm so pleased that we've
got the place that we can start making
steps in the right direction but this is
a family run in and you need your time
out and you need to cut
your dear lady slack you need to learn
The Importance of Being a happy couple
what have you got to say now
so wrapped up in this
and everything we do that
we just
don't even know where to where to go
with romance anymore it's like
I'm so self-consumed
with all of this
just the ability to just have a
conversation with you understanding my
my feelings I have wishes and Ambitions
there are things that
are important to me
they're vitally important to me you'd
have to support that if you're not
prepared to support each other in each
other's roles then it's never ever going
to work you need to be happy together I
want to know what your dreams are again
I haven't heard a Dream from you in
years
I don't even know what you're
transferring I don't know what my dreams
are anymore
I've
quit dreaming I want you to start
dreaming again and then I want you to
share those dreams with me
because I love you
I know you do told all my girls they
were princesses
you are too
I haven't treated you much like royalty
John appreciate me more and see what's
going on inside of here
should matter to him
now that they're talking the game I want
to give Tina John a lesson in something
else they've not done well for a long
time cooking
in any end Country Hotel it's all about
comfort and what I learned immediately
from you is that you're trying way too
hard
you've got a shoe box of a kitchen that
you can't swing a cat in you should be
cooking five course meals in there
okay you're not a chef no I'm not you
shouldn't be on a billboard a delicious
home-cooked meal that's all I'd expect
to see that's all I expect to smell when
you come through that door so I put
together
a list of dishes for the whole week
something you can cook in one pot
fabulous let it cook itself really
fabulous these are my recipes I'm proud
of them don't start improvising change
you just follow them they will work half
an hour to get the chili on yeah
fabulous wait nobody comes here John and
Tina expecting a five course meal the
food was an amazing discovery that it
could be so simple so easy so delicious
I'm glad that Gordon is in my kitchen
tomorrow's a new dawn for the Roosevelt
and my goodness are we going to turn the
page my team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new Roosevelt Inn
good morning good morning or spring in
your step John
how you feeling wonderful good let's go
come in come in come in please okay 16
rooms 32 guests this hotel should be
full welcome to your new honeymoon suite
[Laughter]
a honeymoon suite decluttered bright
Elegance we were literally two centuries
back in time with what we were doing in
these rooms and we are suddenly into now
today it's
donatina I'd like you both to go
upstairs
[Music]
a room that will be great for room
service to have a bit of romance oh this
is just truly beautiful now coupled with
selling those rooms the big asset that
was underused in many ways was
downstairs truly that's been a huge
disappointment for you come with me now
let me show you the new stunning
Roosevelt wedding space
I thought we had something that would be
viable to help build our business and it
was and it was dragging it down oh good
grief oh
look at this whoa okay this is stunning
this is amazing
absolutely amazing color scheme this is
stunning oh my gosh this is the
direction we need to be going in this is
the next step up and I am extremely
grateful and I don't want to see a dog a
dog's hair I dogs chew anywhere in this
space interested now this room should
Propel this business to Greater Heights
it has to be your biggest marketing tool
because when you've got the wedding
books the guests should book every room
upstairs
this space and the revenue it can bring
into the Roosevelt could definitely be
the game changer that we've been looking
for I'd like to point your attention to
those wonderful plates and all the
glassware on the tables
that's a special gift to you worth fifty
thousand dollars no way really
you've now got you know a solid
foundation to host the most amazing
wedding beautiful
there's someone I'd like you to meet
hey please
you may recognize this later
this lady look at our new space
I hope Misty's going to give us a second
chance what strikes you now walking
through that room what's the first thing
that hits you it's just it's natural
it's it's modern it's what the brides
are looking for they're sophisticated
they're young this is what they want and
does it show sort of Versatility in a
way that it can be adapted to suit
different colors absolutely we can put
any color in this room and it'll be
wonderful yay this is gonna sell itself
how does it smell it smells wonderful
[Laughter]
is the good news she is prepared to give
you one more chance to become
curderlands number one venue for hosting
weddings one more surprise John and Tina
Missy's not just here to visit the
Roosevelt
is hosting a wedding tonight tonight
[Music]
owners of the Roosevelt Inn John and
Tina have come a long way from when I
first met them personally because I love
you and professionally I want to make
this work I've just surprised them with
a true test for their business the
Roosevelt is hosting a wedding tonight
wow
tonight when Gordon said we had a
wedding tonight instant gut clenching
terror you're gonna be cooking serving
just simple elegant food
yeah good luck
[Music]
are you a bride hello welcome let me
just take you ladies up to the room all
right go on in ladies
oh my dress guess we're just starting to
ride
[Applause]
[Music]
I gave John and Tina a couple of simple
but delicious wedding recipes that they
could cook in their tiny kitchen and
that I knew the guests would love this
evening is going to be huge for us
you're feeling that that really wound up
sense inside yourself and it's like holy
cow
Donald
Nicole as the couple exchange their vows
downstairs upstairs in the kitchen John
and Tina are proving they are there for
each other when it matters
I give you all that I am I gave you all
that I am and you may kiss your bride
[Music]
you're that side on this side and we go
bang
okay ladies let's go grab them and go
grab them and go
for the first time ever the food at the
Roosevelt is putting a smile on people's
faces
try and bunch them up a little bit just
make look so much neater including
Tina's breathe and talk and okay I've
got this awesome we're a nice rotation
here
John and Tina are a great team when they
communicate properly
I think the buzz they get from tonight
will encourage them to keep working on
their relationship how you doing we're
rocking along here
I love it plates are going away
it's the best thing I've ever had well
done okay how'd you feel where's John
well done oh thank you first time you've
actually cooked yes yeah from scratch
for an amazing wedding well done both of
you thank you
it's been a great night thanks to John
and Tina's teamwork you guys did it even
ahead of schedule
you can do this I'm really hoping that
our future with Misty and our wedding
business just goes through the roof time
to go I'm gonna be a bit sad to leave
this place I think John
Tina done a bloody good job tonight and
more importantly I think the whole
wedding has opened their eyes the huge
potential they've got here
tonight the Roosevelt is fully booked
for the first time in years and the Inn
is back on course for Success it's been
a hell of a week yes tonight proved that
you both can pull this off once we got
the system going it won't work very well
stick together
all right we'll do it like Lou you've
got every chance now good luck you can
have a happy
thank you so much
take care of yourself thank you not
sneak downstairs to that dance floor
in that direction no nice
foreign
[Music]
so gorgeous oh my gosh oh there's an
upstairs thank you Gordon Ramsay for
giving us this opportunity this
experience obviously is not meant to be
easy but in the end
with it so thank you very much it was
nice to say goodbye to him tonight and I
look forward to seeing him again
actually
[Music]